Welcome back everyone maximum effort there's
a new report that more of the original X-Men
characters are coming back for Deadpool 3 and it
lines up with the plot synopsis and how they're
explaining the Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
of it all within messing up all the alternate
timelines alternate universes in the TVA mobias
the Loki characters coming after him if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos it's only going to get crazier
and we're still in the middle of that Spider-Man
across the spider-verse ticket giveaway to apropos
because of the Multiverse of it all I'll name
a new winner during the video the big news is
that a bunch of those original X-Men from those
first couple of X-Men movies are coming back
we know who most of them are there might be some
more that they name along the way but we already
knew about a few a while back the ones we just
found out about are fonka janssen's Jean Grey
she's also the Phoenix obviously Halle Berry's
storm in James marsden's Cyclops and that's in
addition to Patrick Stewart and Ian McKellen
as versions of Professor X and Magneto and
because Hugh Jackman said that he'd be playing
a variant of Wolverine during the movie The same
is probably true of all the other original X-Men
characters we might see some light references to
the original X-Men movies timeline Deadpool made
a bunch of jokes about that during the first movie
mcavoyer Stewart these timelines are so confusing
a joke is so much more timely now a couple years
later to make another timeline reference because
of all the Kang Dynasty Avengers 5 secret Wars
of it all and bringing those X-Men characters
back supports a lot of the rumors about the House
of M storyline that they're using for part of the
movie in addition to Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe everyone's going to be clamoring for
Elizabeth Olsen to have some kind of Cameo as
Scarlet Witch just because of her relationship
with Magneto in the comics because a long time
ago Elizabeth Olsen did say that when they pay
off Magneto being Scarlet Witch's true father
in the movies she wanted it to be a version
of Ian McKellen's Magneto instead of Michael
Fassbender based on their ages it would also
just make more sense if you bring the older
version of Magneto for something like that
uh I'm gonna go with sir Ian McKellen even though
technically because of all the timeline craziness
now and Days of Future Past Michael Fassbender
is now canonically the younger version of Ian
McKellen's Magneto so technically they play the
exact same version of the character as far as I
know Elizabeth Olsen Scarlet Witch isn't in the
movie and when I say House of M plot supposedly
the timeline Deadpool meets Wolverine is inspired
by the events of House of M so there might be some
light references to Scarlet Witch but I don't
think she's in the movie if you didn't read
that comic book storyline that's one of the
most famous X-Men storylines one of the most
famous Scarlet Witch story lines where Magneto
in all mutants Reigns Supreme Over The World
homo Superior compared to Homo sapiens Magneto
basically takes over the entire planet in that
storyline using Scarlet Witch's reality warping
powers like MCU Scarlet Witch creating a massive
hex around the world there were so many theories
about this during one division because it almost
wound up happening like the boundaries of the
hex during the show kept expanding throughout
the episodes eventually it would have covered
most of the planet altering everyone inside who
wasn't powerful enough to withstand her chaos
magic there are only a couple people in the
Marvel universe that are powerful enough to do
that like her chaos magic wouldn't work on the
higher level Cosmic entities or the celestials
the celestials were also immune to the effects
of the snap that's how powerful they're meant
to be but in Deadpool 3 the rumor is that in
the alternate universe Professor X and the X-Men
originally wound up siding with Magneto in the
Brotherhood of mutants instead of fighting against
them during the events of the first X-Men movie
remember during the events of that movie Magneto
is trying to forcibly mutate a giant portion of
the world so the majority of the population
would be mutants and they would reign supreme
over regular humans during the movie Deadpool
supposedly winds up trying to win over that
universe's version of Wolverine played by Hugh
Jackman of course and he'll have a version of the
yellow costume from the comics that also makes it
sound like those other X-Men that are coming back
will wear much more comic book accurate costumes
like the ones from X-Men apocalypse too that would
actually should be pretty cool It ultimately it's
that Universe the Deadpool winds up causing the
destruction of and Kevin feige also said that in
addition to that just like within the scope of
Marvel phase six Deadpool 3 would be a big Tipping
Point with the incursion storyline leading up to
Avengers 5 King Dynasty and Secret Wars a bunch
of universes being destroyed and it sounds like
Deadpool does something so crazy that it winds up
causing a bunch of incursions in tons of universes
get destroyed not just that one and that'll pay
off the Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe part
of the storyline that they're also adapting so
it's kind of like they're combining the Loki
storyline with the TVA with a version of House
of them and Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
one of the other big casting announcements you
probably heard about a little while ago isn't an
X-Men character but they just announced Matthew
McFadden who plays Tom on succession will be
playing a TVA agent assigned by Mobius to follow
a Deadpool and try unsuccessfully but he'll try
to keep Deadpool from messing up other timelines
sounds like he's gonna fail pretty hard they just
had the succession finale too so this is kind of
timely that we talk about his character I believe
his role is going to be sort of Deadpool's comedic
punching bag like a similar type of role that he
plays on succession a hapless idiot who thinks way
too highly of himself that Deadpool just walks all
over Mobius said you're not allowed to mess with
this timeline don't cause any Nexus events and
immediately Deadpool just completely borks the
entire universe the reason they just announced
all the X-Men actors that are coming back is
because they just started filming so they need
the actors to be filming scenes really soon a lot
of times they won't announce characters to like
right before they use them in scenes but a lot of
the characters have talked about coming back Halle
Berry even posted a picture of her with a storm
haircut it sounds like that was in preparation
for filming her Deadpool 3 scenes I did a video a
couple years ago too during the pandemic they had
a big X-Men reunion that Ryan Reynolds crashed
and they had a whole bunch of jokes that were
sort of in the tone of the original Deadpool
movies with Deadpool trying to worm his way
onto the official X-Men team Knots Landing two
professors One Cop what's happening it's just
like the X-Men movies you know it doesn't matter
oh sorry I actually thought this was the Game of
Thrones reunion I love you Patrick Stewart yeah
bye everyone that fell apart quickly oof I guess
it's just you and me Logan I guess so you know
uh you know what that makes this a reunion for
of all the Wolverine Origins jokes I fully
expect them to clown on Wolverine Origins
during the movie several times Ryan Reynolds even
makes more jokes to in real life about that being
completely Hugh Jackman's fault like the debacle
that was Wolverine Origins it was completely Hugh
Jackman's fault they clan on each other all the
time like this in real life they do it to help
promote each other's movies and I cannot wait till
they officially start promoting Deadpool 3 like
when Marvel starts their big marketing campaign
because the original Deadpool marketing campaign
in the Civil War One are probably my two favorites
of almost any movie ever you have to imagine them
doing stuff like this all the time during their
marketing campaign they're gonna have so much
fun you don't even need to release a trailer for
the movie just have them post funny clips like
this clowning on each other you're not on the
team I'm kidding you're on the team you're not
on the team get back over there and sit down
I like it I like it you hit puberty early and
hard what does this suit look like to you huh it
would I mean and I have to spend a year with him
shooting Wolverine and Deadpool and yeah trust me
it would be impossible it'd be a problem so but
just to recap love spirited love will love Octavia
love the song Good afternoon love benj and Justin
but please please from the bottom of my heart
do not validate Ryan Reynolds in this way
please Wolverine and Deadpool because he
kitten not in your life chappy speaking of
the Sabertooth joke they just made because of
the Wolverine Origins I don't know if there's
going to be any kind of saber-tooth Cameo
during the movie he was supposed to be in
the Logan movie for a while he wound up being
a deleted scene though so leave Schreiber said
that he never actually wound up being in the
movie but that he would love to come back as
the Sabertooth character it sounds like they're
using Deadpool 3 as a big swan song for the fox
Marvel movies not just the original X-Men movies
but I think there's supposed to be some original
Fantastic Four actor cameos too I don't know
if that means that Chris Evans is going to
have a human torch Cameo during the movie but
that would be really cool he did have a cameo
during Ryan Reynolds last big movie and the same
director Sean Levy is also directing Deadpool 3.
what the [__] that I mean I don't exactly look
the same anymore I was 15 almost 20 years ago oh
my God um but I really love that character yeah
look I I would love it I would love it that would
actually be an easier sell to me than coming
back as cap you know what I mean cap is right
so precious to me and you know I I almost don't
wanna disrupt what what a beautiful experience
that was but Johnny Storm I feel like he
didn't really get his day that was before
Marvel really found its footing so I you know
I loved that role and you know who knows they
started filming the movie so we should get some
more footage pretty soon of course we'll do more
videos as we get more details congratulations
to coffee shakes you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details my Spider-Man across the
spiderverse review will post tomorrow everyone
click here to learn about the new Fantastic Four
movie cast and click here for my Loki season 2
trailer video in Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!